for many the holidays mean time with
family some siblings here in clark
county though aren't so lucky they're
broken up into different foster homes
but today saint jude's ranch for
children helped bring them together for
an early christmas celebration victoria
saha was there she joins us live in
studio with more victoria
these siblings only get to see each
other a couple of times a year so they
do their best to make sure every
precious moment they have together
counts especially during the holidays
some of joshua hutron's siblings i love
you guys
he's now 18 years old but growing up he
was forced to raise them for a while my
mom was just always kind of
just putting the kids on the older civic
until child protective services got
involved the other two the youngest they
went to foster foster home i went to a
group home
holidays are tough when they're
separated which is why the event hosted
by saint jude's ranch for children is so
important lutron's siblings along with
75 other children were able to fill the
adventure dome at circus circus and just
focus on family time with rides and
presents events like this are good
because i get
and count down the days until they meet
again
i got a chance to speak with the ceo of
this program she says these kids already
go through so much and the holidays come
with a lot of stress she's just thankful
for the generous donations from the
community to make this event so special
sasha